what happened
[Applause]
driving Brobee did Eagles ever gone
Kanda
I think we finally made it rich I don't
know Robbie honey ready in a minute
taken it one more journey bum [ __ ] holy
cat ah Richard unbelievable what a road
what about it Henri water Oh Rama twelve
seasons going into old numbers art in
honey when when we started on the show
yeah here in our detox and fitzy it was
weird
being 15 in detox we're trendsetters bum
okay trendsetters for those of you who
might be like oh no new to school in the
wrong room or way in the back and unable
to say anything
this little blurry dot is Rob Benedict
you know
and this little fuzzy thing is Richard
Speight jr. he played Gabriel and most
recently he's director of Supernatural
yeah o3o starting lineup and free right
into it shall we
right so yeah just look at can see they
can see but we brought our own singer
please welcome executive Brewster and
showrunner of Supernatural mr. Bob
singer oh don't even oh that stings
they're in Amanda's note up know you
spent this backstage uh next to him
taking the stage America's favorite
Ackles
[Applause]
that's up next up a man whose hair is
get it getting its own spin-off series
yeah new mr. Jared okay yeah I can't
wait to see a show about crime-fighting
hair yeah would be great too and last
but not least not only is this gentleman
a showrunner but all Phil the inventor
of a new dance move
Andrew Deb Wow guys congratulations on
another amazing season season 12
thank you sir let out who rules with a
sidebar at that opening
so so we had we had fun moments
backstage because these boys obviously
wanted to watch the show so they were
trying on masks to see what would hide
them and I can tell you after surveying
all the masks in the room no masks work
okay really does not it's hard to hide
the hair in the bow legs your enemy
another it tells the story but seriously
I mean this is a hell of a year this has
been unbelievable season so much
craziness
what were your favorite episodes with
this season 12 and 20 those are the ones
he directed yeah other one is ready you
are you got a favorite rubble the other
21
you're a jerk um no seriously at the
finale I thought the finale wasn't a
finale was about that finale
congratulations on surviving in the
finale you're the only two there were
the only two yeah it was a play with a
bloodbath yeah so uh yeah I really was I
mean Rowena's tells she she's literally
toast yeah toast
and Crowley sacrifice yeah and mom is
locked in another dimension with Lucifer
kind of a dream date scenario yeah uh
and then I mean yes Mia I got a buddy I
got anything to do this buddy I got to
do this Bobby
really you really killed Castiel you
know we we have said over the course of
time one thing that keeps the show fresh
and why we've gone into our thirteenth
season is you say when we when we write
these things that you have to go where
the story takes you and Andrew and
myself and the other writers we've
thought that perhaps some Castiel's time
come play play frankly and I think the
guys will back me up on this Misha has
become a bit of a prima donna what
should be number one of the quality
[Applause]
um
ah I'm sorry nice I guess I I was back
there but they never told me to come out
but I heard my name so I assumed
ah this is awkward well this just got
really weird
yeah you just show you what we do you
know you stop Ron's going to keep
crossing and go off on our tired I'll
just press right here oh well now I
guess maybe we should just ask him
what's it like to not be on the show
anymore yeah
[Music]
Misha he's excited that did take the
story where it went but I'm not going
away then he's gonna drop my set
you grab service you secondly yeah
that's nice
adults talking and uh in America well
clearly be she is here and he's going to
be back but but he is a prima donna
I will say now that leashes on stage
there are a few people that love you but
there was a really so so for the first
time in 13 years
ackles and I would like we're not going
to wait backstage while Kansas plays we
want to be in the audience so they snuck
us way into the back corner so we could
watch while Kansas was playing and a
lovely young lady who was back there and
you know who you are got up and sort of
dancing and then she's like it turns
over and here's Misha and she's like hey
will you take my oh my god
hey will you take black
[Applause]
a full-on circle I'm gonna be sure Vigo
so well she has that experience but now
there's a whole bunch of people to that
corner going wait a minute just wait a
minute
here's to the Mesa where I tell myself
mama so let's talk about clubbing Venus
actually yes relevant to 13 you know
after that finale
what are you what's the plan from here
where do you go from there well episode
1 Castiel dies yeah
I let Andrew handle that one sure well I
think for us season 12 by the end of
season 11 when mom comes back season 12
the guys kind of had the happiest
situation that could have mom's back all
the friends are alive they saved the
world without having a sacrifice each
other and season 12 was you really
missed that up didn't you yeah told
everybody yeah and then in season 13
we're like well that was a horrible idea
like too much every nice and we want
that so then we just murder which is
which is really what the show is based
on it's just multiple serial homicides
that everyone in this audience is
witness to and probably will be indicted
for but that's a longer conversation
you're all cooler right collusion
there's something great about listening
to Andrew talk seriously about the show
while in the monitor teeny tiny little
Misha sits next to him at the kids table
[Laughter]
here we can we um talking to the
producers here can we make this happen
on set can he have just a little chair
no more big I didn't know he was allowed
to sit I thought it was initely speak
but - so listen one of the big
characters we saw at the end of the
season we saw Lucifer he got himself a
little boy has a son Jack now this uh we
see this character very briefly curled
up naked in the corner which is actually
he'll Rob started on the show Azen to my
trailer
before being called a set that was
crying okay weird but Jack is that you
know have Lucifer have mortals so
there's a lot of moral ambiguity at play
here Andrew you want to talk about that
and where does this character house this
character going to play into the season
and and how do you think it'll develop
over time yeah well I mean as you
mentioned which most of how we see the
character is naked and I think it's an
important element to add you know
dynasties coming on we have to compete
that's just the way I look at it and if
so if you were to die at the end of
season 12 like somebody on this stage
would you come back naked um you know I
mean I don't know that we can afford the
blur effects honestly like it's just oh
you need you mean because it's like so
much of the screen would have to be yeah
yeah
gotcha gotcha I mean that's what I've
been told by hair and makeup
so well I know you I know what you mean
because you'd have to you'd have not
just one blur you'd have to have three
blurs yeah well actually four cuz of the
third nipple yeah so yeah I think it's
great to have this conversation because
we all know Jarrod's been very honest on
his Twitter feed yeah and I think it's a
healthy for for him to discuss this
stuff that was so brave so brave so
accurate so brave I will say that after
and I had I had several friends and
family members call me to say like dude
did you twittering some stuff like huh
so to tell you from my end of the story
we're out we're in Chicago a couple days
a week ago and I go to bed about eleven
o'clock and I get some sleep and I wake
up at four o'clock
to like go to the bathroom or something
and I have all these like your twitter
was favorited your Twitter was like your
twitter was favorited your Twitter was
like my Twitter like that I tweet
something and then I have your tweet is
really gaining traction your tweet is
gaining traction make a comment and I
was like and so then I have one text
message
not from Jensen from Missha not from Bob
or Andrew or richer
to rob its format Cohen and I was like
Matt is he okay because he's not the
type to text me at like 2:00 in the
morning so I open it up and it just says
dude Twitter so I opened my Twitter I
didn't realize he's fluent and Ackles
that's it Claire hey blacken it may have
been Twitter dude or dude it was but
those two words I remember the order and
so then I opened my Twitter and I'm like
that's the last time I hand my phone
over to Misha Collins in fairness I
think it was two years ago at comic-con
that I posted you were like you grabbed
my phone when I when we were signing and
apparently I post it on Twitter
I hate fans ah which is a great post at
comic-con and for the rest of the
signing everybody was coming up like we
hate you to be sure that's right I
remember you're in tannic set in because
we do a signing after this and we're
signing in you pass and you sign you
pass and then Misha upon realizing that
so he had just put his phone on the
table and it was on and I was like see
he he he he put it back upon I think I
think like you got a bunch of phone
calls or something he was like oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god I got a
head of like excuse himself you've done
that to almost all of us and that's we
were high-fiving when we saw that tweet
never yeah one time I got him yeah
that's why you didn't get a lot of
warning phone calls from Craig but uh
bring it back so uh Jensen how how will
Dean and Sam react to this Jack
character uh differently dude cool I
told you they're going to make this hard
I said I begged you not to ask some
questions go to your let's go to your
notes there's been a lot of build up for
this I mean whole seasons been dealing
with every line and it's obviously
they're the mom being gone and gas and
all of this kind of
turmoil that the brothers find
themselves and now they have this person
this this thing this entity and in
Dean's mind just simply has to go but
because technically it's half human
the ever optimistic Sam Winchester was a
female of human half human got it oh
there's a weird I'm in a weird echo spot
so I'm catching a vortex so they're
there how female vo week we have two
different ideas of how how to handle the
situation does Jared know we're doing a
panel
I'm Jessica Kate again nobody wait no
panel for comic-con right now okay
anyway but I'd yeah that character could
go either way could be evil could be
have Sam and Dean encountered somebody
with use of characteristics before the
sort of the half Lucifer half human is
they wrestled this moral dilemma
previously to this degree it's kind of
difficult right I'm trying to get the
last time well no this is this is the
spawn of the devil so right yeah which I
don't know why anyone would want to see
how that works out
you know what let's see how this plays
out what could possibly go wrong
Dean's a little more practical I have an
idea let's shoot it in the face in Sam's
a bit like I might just piss it off I
think at least we'll know through that's
true I think Sam I do toes to Bob and
Andrew and the rest of our writers it's
it's it's a neat we've danced around
this a couple times but not to this
degree
the whole nature versus nurture argument
and so it is Jack certainly is half
lucifer but he's also have kelly kline
right and kelly kline was a good person
and so
Sam uh but the optimist is trying to
figure out what to do in Dean being Dean
shoot first ask questions later
has his idea and some things never
change and andrew is that a journey that
will that Jack himself will go on in his
sort of development and trying to figure
out which side he's he's on yeah I mean
I think in terms of the character you
know obviously as John has talked about
the guts strong opinions I think from
Jared's would it be precision of Sam's
point of view Sam was the character who
was as we remember from way way back
destined to do very bad things and oh
yeah and still make a lot of lot of
years left but he's selling or not I
don't I don't really know um but uh but
the idea that I think Sam can kind of
put themselves and put himself in that
shoot no shoes a little bit better and
then for Jack himself he's someone who I
think is struggling with that and will
continue to struggle with that in our
version of hell's my two dads and then
Misha
um so you've been doing a lot of
gardening or yeah so you can um you
can't plant tomatoes until July so
that's what I'm getting into now that's
great faith anywho thanks buddy
um and so some mom mom is trapped in
this other dimension this other world
right and so much Robbie of this season
so much of the season you were there was
a the Mary character wonderfully played
by Samantha Smith you guys had a service
that story really well and the way Sam
reacted to Mary in the way the Dean was
reacting to Mary and how you guys were
coping it for her return dealing with
the British minute letters now that
she's had this experience and is now you
know made this move to try to do the
right thing and now find herself on the
other side of this wall oh they have in
this hole
how do Sam and Dean differ in their
approach to how to handle that situation
Dean thinks she's gone that she went
through the rift to rift rich not a hole
I was just making sure you read the
notes okay she went through the rift the
hole with Lucifer and the whole rift
closed and Dean is pretty sure that
that's that's curtains for mom and and
while he's bereft over that he's ready
to accept that Sam thinks no she went
through alive we've been on the other
side of this rift he's holding on to the
fact that she could still be alive and
that's a bit of a it's a problem between
the guys because Sam's mission in the
beginning part of season 13 is let's
find mom and Dean's ideas we have bigger
fish to fry mom's dead you're just going
to have to come to that realization
spoiler alert
mom is not dead I told you right I told
you come with me
Dean's kind of a debbie downer at the
beginning of the season beanie downer
wah wah wah wah wah
let's kill jack mom is dead everybody's
dead yeah good I didn't know mom wasn't
it not like that
read the scripts he hasn't read of
scripts in season seven that's what
we're on right at season seven and so in
the Mary storyline by the way Mary who
is in would lose burden ism and the
other side of the wrist is uh she's got
her own journey she's got her own
challenges to face now and Andrew how do
we see that playing out for her yeah I
mean I think in terms of Mary IV she
came back she came back with a very you
know first very kind of spun out she
even asked to come back she was brought
back she was sent back it took her a
while to find her footing I think you
know with the world at large and more
specifically with her sons and by the
end of the season I think there were
everyone was in a very good place she's
been lost you know over on the other
side here she's got someone who as far
as Mary's concerned she made that
sacrifice knowingly she went through
that rift knowingly like I don't know
that she is necessarily you know that
that's something she's kind of I think
comes to terms with
doesn't mean she's not active that
doesn't mean she who doesn't to make
this world a better place because the
world she's gone into is far worse in
the world in which our guys live day to
day and then I also think you know one
of the interesting things about Jack is
that as we know the only person has ever
opened a rift to this world is Jack so
if Jack is the key to getting back one
how do you convince them to do that can
you give in and do that and do you want
him to do that because you're just
opening a hole to an apakah which has
been ravaged by the apocalypse you know
you look at you hope that doors one way
but maybe it's not and so I think those
are all things everyone's kind of
struggling with yeah and I think you
brought up a good point that she did it
knowingly so Mary sacrifice herself for
the good of the Winchesters Crowley
sacrificed himself for the good of the
Winchesters did anybody else die in the
finale not the big round did not
sacrifice themselves for for somebody
else's good not that I'm aware of
I'm willing to read recaps Twitter if
you want to let me know but no I mean a
big part of the final episode would you
had all these people and really a lot of
part of the season you had a lot of
people who came to get it was really
about how Samedi impacts each other but
also other people so you saw how they
impacted other hunters you saw the how
they impacted you know Crowley and
Rowena and Castiel and so a lot of part
a lot of you know what ended up being
our last two episodes a lot of people
Jody Mills
a lot of people stepping up and
essentially you know do helping the
Winchesters in the winters has helped so
many people but that was really
important to us to build a sense of
community and then because it's
supernatural you tear it all down but
you know over the versus a season that
was really what it was about and then
speaking of this apocalypse
apocalyptical [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] elliptic I
guess and piece of exercise equipment I
was on that's like 20 minutes on the
apocalyptical this morning we give this
apocalyptical world what we went where
what haven't was a so we saw Bobby who
yeah and what this other world seems to
do was it's another alternate reality so
it's Ronnie but it's a it's Bobby living
a different life he doesn't know the
boys right
so is this world could that open up for
other characters to reappear in the same
way
do you have anybody specific I mean I
got sounds more like a pitch than a
question well I'm just curious does God
like how does where does god am i coming
back Bob you are god of the universe but
it's a really big universe yeah you know
it's possible it depends how you do here
today oh crap
Gabriel I don't think so come on we'll
do our own spin-off rich fine mama so
but but so that world could open up to
bring some other characters back it
definitely could use by the way by the
way because we love to tease rich and we
don't know if Gabriel I mean love that
character but I think for first and
second time directing Richard Speights
direction on this show has been just
fantastic and we're just so happy with
Richard thank you a huge compliment
think about appreciative can you tease
any characters that will be back or no
you know we're not doing that yet I
think by the way but by T's he means
give them a hard time okay add polka
people I know I think we've got some
cool characters coming back both in our
world and in the apocalypse world so
that's the fun of it is you know we've
got some people coming back like you
know Missouri Moseley is going to come
back for us for the first time in a long
time you know obviously Jody will be
back for us sentimental to like that and
then in Apocalypse world without getting
to spoilers
some people who have been long dead on
our show are less dead in apocalypse
world and much different character
[Applause]
that's my goodness it's more injured
it's promising so my phone change
shifted my eye very shifty you know
we're talking about a show that has been
on since half this room wasn't born and
we were going 13 years into a show and
the thing I think that makes
Supernatural special in the world of
television for not just us revolted it
but also for you folks who watch it is
that it continues to reinvent itself it
continues to be interesting tell fun
stories so engaging stories that are
emotional and and connect with the
audience and that's all if I may say
driven by the fabulous performances of
you two gentlemen who continue to do
outstanding work Misha came along and
slowed it down for a while but now he's
gone and we get back to the business of
making quality TV so for you for your
journey still may not be funny anymore
this is the best day of my life but if
we can be reflective for a moment about
and Bobby been with the show since is
beginning as well so the questions for
all three of you season 1 - now how is
your experience been and how is your
relationship with both the show and you
in your case Jensen and Jared your
characters how has it evolved over this
long period of time that's an easy
question um that was the last 13 years
of your life great thanks for asking
yeah thank you good night
Peggy a good night that is hard to you
know speak quickly about the experience
that we've had obviously it's the
longest job I've ever held and and I
guess one of my favorite thing one of
many things that I love about doing this
job is that we're never doing the same
thing twice every day is a new
experience we're telling different
stories there's new characters to
introduce and old characters to finally
get rid of and
it's that kind of crappy acting that got
you fired
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's I made look it's been wonderful the
experience has been great you know we've
we've had we've had her ups and downs we
had was a great seasons we've had maybe
not so great seasons it's been it's an
ebb and flow and but I think through it
all it is it has been wonderful and I'm
very proud to be a part of something
that's lasted this long
yeah I agree with everything he just
said I think for me also it was kind of
specifically and it's hard it's
difficult for me to identify the chicken
and the egg not that I would even know
which came first anyways full ones but
is a bird hahahahaha
one of the other old Twitter's I really
move that's right got it that's what it
is the help no it's a but jared was a
lot Jared and Sam were sort of similar
season one in that I was like man this
is hard work like it's this is difficult
to be up in Vancouver I had no friends I
was living in a hotel room we didn't
know if we had a job for more than two
months because we hadn't been picked up
for a season we hadn't even really aired
yet so we didn't have any we didn't have
this family which is badass that we have
now to support oh and there was nothing
Twitter didn't exist I don't mean maybe
it existed but it wasn't like oh well
I'm getting support from my friends that
aren't here
iPhones didn't exist iPhones that's
right came out like season one right I
know Jesus loved you back so come so it
gradually as the show was
going on both Sam and Jared have
realized that this is life and life is
pretty great it can be it can have its
absent flows to bar what he was talking
about its ups and downs it's good days
and bad days but it's wonderful and to
look out here after 13 years and see how
many thousand people jumping around and
dancing and can visit here yeah yeah I
met my wife on the show we have three
cries she's somewhere out there but
let's changed a lot ha ha ha not
touching I had one one thing even though
I wasn't there at the beginning we were
talking on I know I'm new and now I'm
gone but we were talking about this on
Friday someone asked us about a question
about sort of the eventual demise of the
characters in the end of the show and
Jensen started talking about it a vision
that he had had dreamed that he had had
about how about the demise about the end
of the show and about Sam
dying and the amazing thing about it was
when he was describing this dream the
three of us kind of got choked up
because we all know these characters so
well they're so a part of us that the
that we have actually sort of taken them
into our own emotional family if that
makes any sense they feel real to us and
so it the thought of Jensen as Dean
losing Sam is actually like
heartbreaking which is kind of amazing
and that could only possibly happen I
think with the show that's been running
for this long that was what was
remarkable when I went back at the end
of season 11 and you go up a couple
times a year just direct like the
enthusiasm is all still there the
writing is still 100% you know and these
two you guys are doing work that I'm
like wow Season eleven twelve thirteen
of a show you think people are phoning
it in you're absolutely not voting in
that's why it's continually consistently
great let me just tell one story that I
think really crystallizes the
relationship that
everyone has in the show I was directing
in episode I can't remember which one we
were going to do a scene with Jared and
Jensen about 30 minutes before we're
supposed to shoot the scene they come to
me and they say I think we should switch
parts
I think what's written for Dean is
actually should be Sam and vice-versa
and I said really guys now you come to
me with this I think we had already
blocked the scene and they were lighting
it and we went to but same exact we're
like hey I think I should take all of
Dean's lines and Jen's and you take all
of Sam's lines you know changing beena
because we were we were we were
rehearsing it we were running it and it
just we were kind of tripping over the
dialogue of bed and where's like what
something's someone's not reading it was
you you were like let's try something
and we've never ever done this and
haven't done it sense but he was like
you read all of Sam's lines as Dean and
I'll take all the deans lines reading
the same okay so we tried it and it was
it just worked we're like you know the
light bulb went off we went over to Bob
and said Bob hey one of our producer
writers to tell him like hey we're gonna
completely change the entire scene and
flip the dialogue and of course he
probably thought it was a joke no you
had a serious look but I was going
around how is this that were actors Bob
were actors so so we went on we went off
into a corner and they did it and I
heard it and I said yeah that's right
you guys are absolutely right we had a
reblock a little bit not nothing
terrible but the idea I think that
they're always in the moment like this
and thinking about what they do and also
that I think they feel comfortable
enough with what the producing staff to
you know to come up and sort of want to
make this honest change and that we are
comfortable enough with the actors to
know that this is not about ego or
anything else this is just about making
the show better and the relationship
that I think we all have is really
special and getting back to why I'm
still here I think is because these
relationships are are really dear to me
and
I just appreciate every day that I can
work on the show that's fantastic I
think it's I think it's said again I
couldn't said it better I think it's
it's we obviously and I think y'all in
the audience know this as much as we
tease the short one at the end and we
all truly enjoy each other as people
it's not fake like hey let's go pretend
to have a bite to eat
so someone takes a picture and alissa
we're friends we we have we have
legitimate friendship aside from working
together but that doesn't always
translate onto the page or on to the
screen or into the work environment but
I feel like especially 13 years in we
have a lot of trust with each other like
if I feel like I I remember a scene and
Croatoan season 2 or 1 and we were doing
a scene where Sam had been infected and
thought he was going to die and for
whatever reason it hit Jared too hard
and I was like crying crying crying way
like way too far
it was everything really wasn't it's not
inking button but but they weren't they
weren't Sam's tears and so Bob I didn't
realize that I was like man I really
broke down like that must look that must
this is going to be a cool scene because
like I was legitimately just crying my
eyes out and Bob came up and just kind
of like I think he's like hey everybody
take five minutes because I it stayed
with me and he kind of came in he's like
hey that was a great take I want you to
take a minute and just do it again and
just dial it back a little bit you know
go there no but it wasn't like and he
was he was he was it was gentle and kind
and honest as a director to go to an
actor who just broke down and one like
that you clearly went somewhere and it
was touching but that that wasn't Sam
and he was absolutely right and I was
like got it and I think that's kind of
when I was like maybe you don't member
maybe you remember it but yeah it was I
trusted him just like he said with a
there's there's trust here aside from
our personal friendship there's a lot of
trust that they care about the show and
the characters they know that Jensen and
I
about Dean and Sam you know so you know
the show has become a shows about family
but the show is a family it's clear when
you see it from the outside when you
visit as an actor when you visit as a
director from the whole crew from do you
guys all the way down the list and in LA
it's a family and it's an it's a
aggressive thing to witness Julius and
the other member of the family by the
way the fans so now let's take some
bobby I mean let's open it up let's take
questions for the fans all right let's
do it
hello first I wanted to say loved the
show my question isn't really a question
my daughter has social anxiety which is
why I'm speaking for her but we just
wanted to say thanks both to Jared well
actually all you guys for all the
different you know what's word charities
charities and and different you know
causes causes Thank You
organizations that you guys have set up
for people like me who can't talk or you
know her with her social anxiety but she
just I can see it from her or through
her how she's grown just from the
support that you give even not knowing
her personally and then one side note
Misha thank you for the doughnuts this
morning
[Applause]
nice to meet you what's your daughter's
name Kaylie Bailey
nice to meet you that's very very brave
of you to stand up in front of thousands
of people very funny
[Applause]
let's be honest it's embarrassing to see
Misha suck up that hard to the pan thing
that's not going to change the outcome
he eats each donut you look at the
wrapper it said please if you take this
donut please tweet and read a bring me
back it was actually a finding contract
if you take this donut we have to send
him hate mail and talk him back
I don't know if you love will for coming
into town save passing it all thanks
guys
all right huge fan I had a question
about what was your favorite prop Jensen
Misha and jarred like throughout the
show and yeah I really love you guys let
me back my favorite props got something
to drop baby is not a problem
[Applause]
no baby is a part of me I you know we
get to we get to play and use so many
tools weapons I will say that one of the
one of the weapons that we we play
around with quite often the angel blade
is one of my favorites because of the
weight of it and I just constantly am
spinning it in my hand and it's it kind
of reminds me it's you know the little
what are they called fidget spinner
since it's gonna it's the original
original phase III og fidget spinner my
favorite prop is Dean
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's why he's no longer with us
i I think the hair you know he does have
is the best to pay in the business it
really is yes I am going to say the
demon blade the Rubies demon blade not
for obvious reasons
but there's another funny thing that I
don't know if y'all know this
some of y'all have maybe seen prop demon
blade which is kind of ironic or baby of
like saying Nile River or something
so Sahara Desert sorry so some of y'all
have seen that like replica diamond
blades the Rubies knife it was actually
put together incorrectly when it first
got on camera
the handle is improperly yes upside like
the handle should be backwards way
compared to where the serration is and
the blade is and for some reason I found
that out early on and it always occurs
to me whenever I hold it because when
you hold it not like their scenes where
I have to pull it out of my back pocket
or something and I put it in a certain
way expecting the handle to fit organ ah
mcclee a certain way and he pull it out
and the blade is facing me and I'm like
I'm gonna do that again
and then pull it out and it's ready but
I really dig the the demon blade hi my
name is Viviana and I wanted to ask in
the episode yellow fever people died
from their fears so I was wondering what
would you die of basically what what
fears do we have that we would die from
I don't have fear bears
I'm just kidding I guess that for me it
would be just being up when a little
that went heart disease I mean
statistically speaking never film likely
[Laughter]
for me I think it would be just being
like it's like a classic sort of fear
but it would be being up on stage with
Al in front of a large number of people
with my friends making fun of me if it
is in a little boy chair in a tiny tiny
chair I don't know what what what fear
would you die oh wow and he doesn't and
he didn't even get a doughnut Bob singer
never got it doughnut oh that dude oh oh
yeah
Bob thank you easy you are you are so
fired
like Justin had dusted by the way the
culprit today I think walked right into
that so fear where'd you land on how
like you area in the pier bed I don't
know um I I would say this about 13
years ago this probably would have
killed me
the this is not I mean we're up here
talking and having a good time and
making jokes but it's it's daunting I
mean there are a lot of people in this
audience and to get up and try to speak
eloquently and not trip over your words
or just not trip is is brief can be
pretty frightening so I've been able to
face that and kind of get over it and
now I'm here and there there isn't much
beer but years ago that certainly would
have been one for me how about daddy I
think I'm in love
JJ first date daughter's first date
night uh yes boys in my daughter's life
yeah fear number one I get that
what is it the the guns don't kill
people dads with pretty little girls
[Laughter]
all right you yes ma'am you hi um I am
going to be the last question
so I hope it's good my name is Megan
this is Jensen yes dad
and maybe yeah maybe gonna be named baby
please named baby baby oh just Jensen
oh you're not nice well God that that
name served me well I hope it's her if
you will what is my name
Michael Archangel yelling okay sorry
question which character do you feel
would make the most interesting I don't
know no sir
what we very much feel as we have really
really strong female character in the
show e OD mill know that on handsome
Alex film and we feel they would make an
extremely exciting initiatives for
having me there we go that gentleman
here we are we are the end of yet
another panel San Diego comic-con nobody
literally goes what yeah it is certainly
shocked I know so any parting words of
the people gathered here today yes
thank grow
and I think we've kind of rustling
herbivore but we exist like this because
you all exist like that so this is this
is 5050 hero on stage but this is a much
knowledge of us thank all for giving us
the chance to play these characters and
on the story ladies and gentlemen thank
you guys everybody say hello and goodbye
to Andrew down pop singer meet the goin
gets a licking and mr. Jensen Ackles
thank you guys Thank You San Diego
you